hello YouTube just lowers my friends
this is grunge in here welcome to the
brand-new dirty chess trick series
against Sicilian in this lecture I'm
going to show you some of the amazing
and wonderful tricks against Sicilian
dragon variation which arises after the
Mordor efore c5 Knight where three d6
and in the first rate we are going to
see the open radiation that is d4c
captures d4 Knight captures d4 Knight to
f6 attacking Evo and when I defended
with the move Knight to c3 the trademark
dragon move that is g6 so idea is very
simple
black wants to play the move Bishop to
g7 castle on the King side and then
start attacking white on the queenside
well it sounds all good except White has
this amazing move that is f4 which
completely stopped the chakra g7 now
let's see what happens if black plays
the move Bishop to g7 which is a case of
many Dragon player as they will turn out
this move automatically here is the
answer why it has this amazing stunner
that is e Phi BAM the further
continuation is D captures Aoife and
after F captures ePHI most of the Dragon
players has tried this three locations
for the night but all miserably fail
let's look at each biter
if black plays the move Knight to g4
then after just one that is Bishop to
defy check that can pack his back and go
home the first obvious response which
black cannot play that is Knight to c6
because after Knight captures and pawn
captures and Bishop captures at least
what we gained in exchange in this
radiation so that is not playable if
black block the check with either bishop
of the night so let's say fish up to d7
then
the news is even bust because now what
can simply become a piece of after Queen
captures G for the worst of all is if
black try to run away from the check
with the King that is skin to a fade
then after Knight to e6 yep
the queen is a goner so we can easily
conclude this that Knight to g4 is a
unplayable move the second one I want to
consider is the move Knight to d7 but
after this white can play the movie six
attacking the knight and please note
black cannot capture the e6 pawn because
black lose the bishop
so here most of the cases dragon player
has tried the Moon Knight to f6 but
after a further continuation that is he
captures f7 King captures f7 and Bishop
to c4 once again King cannot go to the
effort Square because of the night to e6
check that killer defense is to play the
movie 6 and I have reached this position
in few of my games and I'd like to show
you one of my quick wins in this line so
here I continue with the move castle on
the kingside my opponent responded with
the move look to d8 so his idea is to do
an artificial castle I responded with
the move Bishop to g5 pinning tonight
and finally he evacute his king with the
move King to g8 yes
Black has achieved artificial castle but
for the cost of a very bad position
which occurs after the move Knight to e4
look at that pathetic knight on f6 it is
attacked by three of the white pieces
and the only good way to keep him alive
is to play the move Knight B to d7 but
after this move the e6 square becomes
severely weak and exploit that
magnificently in the key here I continue
with the move Knight to d6
attacking rook and after rook to e7
finally I grab the e6 pawn with my
knight black ass the only good response
laughs that is Queen Shaq and after King
to h1 black has to do something about
this discover check which my opponent
did by playing the Mook into HH and now
it's just a matter of technique
after few calculation I first of all
destroy the defender of the key which is
Knight captures g7 and after King
captures g7 I continue with the move
Queen to d2 so there are some tricks
based on Bishop to at six
my opponent immediately evacuate his key
with the mu Qing 2hh but actually it
turns out that this is a big mistake
before I show you my next move I want
you to pause the video and find out the
best move for the white I hope you find
this move that is Queen to c3 this move
conforms the white victory there are
three pcs attacking the f6 Knight which
cannot be protected further hear my
opponent find nothing better than
capturing the knight on d6 but after
rook captures f6 my opponent tries the
resign pattern so you can see the game
can finish very very quickly the third
move I want to consider is the move
Knight to d5 well after this move once
again what is going to give this chat
with the bishop and this time around
black cannot put any pcs in between the
only move left is King to f8 so it's
already an achievement by Miss placing
black Queen however why it has amazing
attacking ideas to illustrate this once
again I like to show you one of my own
quick game here I continue with the
castle so now I'm threatening the movie
six so my opponent played c6 himself
I further continue with my piece
development that is Queen to have three
and same time creating a mating Treach
which luckily my opponent spotted so he
played the move Queen to c7 and now I
played a very tricky move that is Bishop
to g5 which at first sight looks doing
nothing on g5
but my opponent's next move that is
Knight to c6 which is double question
mark move I want you to pause the video
and find out the finishing blow okay
I hope you find this mu that is light
capture c6 pawn captures and now the
trick which my opponent missed is Bishop
to D H BAM
unfortunately black cannot capture the
bishop because there's a mate on f7 so
Queen has to steal on the sounds rang my
opponent responded with the move Queen
to b7
but after Bishop captures c6 there is no
escape so these are some of the
wonderful tricks against open variation
of Dragon please remember this
f4 mu which will serve you very very
well now there is another good trick in
the Dragon which start at this point
with the more order b3 the usual
response of the Dragon player is to play
the move Knight to f6 attacking a foe
but this time we're on y can play this
move e5 d captures Aoife and Knight
captures ePHI it looks like White has
done a blunder because if you carefully
look at this position right now both
Knight and rookies are hanging and if
black wants black and play this move
that is Queen to d4 at first sight it
looks like black is winning but believe
it or not this is exactly white once
here white will continue with the move
Bishop
b5 check and the main move is Knight B
to d7
if black responded with the move Bishop
to d7 then the simplest is and Knight
captures Bishop and after Queen captures
rook Knight captures f6 where it has two
pcs for a rook and if we check out this
position with the computer it will
definitely give a great advantage to the
white so that's why this is not possible
so the main move is Knight B to d7
afterwards it doesn't look like White
has any trick left but here comes
another stunner that is Knight to c4 so
what's the idea
well idea is very simple what white
wants to do is to capture the night on
d7 with a check and when black recapture
white can play the move Knight to c3 and
come out from the odd threat so if black
wants the piece then he has to take it
right now so the obvious move we want to
consider is what happens after Queen
captures a one well this is a case where
we invite a case to smack him off yes
true here white will continue with the
move Bishop to b2 attacking the Queen
and after the only reply that is Queen
captures a to white is simply going to
play the move Bishop captures f6 no
matter how black recapture let's say e
captures f6 Knight to c3 and bye-bye
miss Queen so please watch out this
amazing Queen trap in Sicilian red
invitation I hope you enjoy and learn
this amazing tricks in Sicilian dragon
variation please feel free to like
subscribe and comment on my video and I
will meet you in my next episode bye